[Music]
this is your last careers lesson
so does anyone have a realistic career
plan tyson
denzel what about you youtubers i keep
telling you all you've got to keep
things real jamie
jamie knew me what do you want to be
a performer for a minute there i had
such high hopes for you
what is wrong with our boy you remember
when we was little
please flat dress up well for me
that's a game i don't want to stop
playing i'm done with this
i wanted a sun so badly i got you
the cold empty moon
i don't think i've got a dad anymore
you've done nothing wrong jamie you
never did
so why do you want to be on stage
i want to be a drag queen because it's
all i ever dream of
i'm gonna close my eyes it's all i can
see
[Music]
if jamie wants to come to prom he comes
just just like all the other boys
you are a freak they made me feel so
ugly
i'm scared you can't just be a violent
dress jamie
obama dress is something to be laughed
at
a drag queen should be feared you won't
believe the power it gives you
i don't just want to be one i have to be
one stop waiting for permission
you are the bravest person i know you're
like beyonce
no mom
do you ever wish i were just normal
no never
[Applause]
and you don't even know it your room's
so tidy i don't know how you do it i
don't have as many dresses as you do
you